cette émission qui a la chance de
continuer puis cartonne grâce à une
seule et unique personne jean capin
résidents de cette chaîne notre
président chérif nm foca piéto
magnifique d'ailleurs si on avait chacun
un mot à dire sur tout ce qui touche à
en prendre deux au hasard valérie bénaïm
professionnalisme vous exceptionnel vous
le talent le talent vous drôle vous la
politesse il dit bonjour tu vas là il va
nous dire mais je pense que la même mais
pas nous dire adieu
je l'appelle grand capitou ya un instant
on peut diffuser un rambo avec rambo
idées tous les soirs sur ces vides ça
devient un tube à vous l'attendiez tous
les soirs et j'avais pas validé chez eux
comme une erreur de ne pas regarder ce
combo ce rambo sache que les personnes
qui ont fait ça je vais me retrouver
on va les retrouver ses rangs châtier
tout ce qui est dit là dedans mais bien
entendu c'est fou il n'y a qu'un seul et
unique patron dans cette chaîne c'est
bien toi franck je le sais mon bébé tant
régime au bébé allez on va pas être une
caméra sur la régie et on va rediffuser
ce rambo avec notre président qui va le
voir en direct s'il vous plaît est ce
qu'on peut avoir
si au ps qu'on peut avoir tout de suite
le duplex de la régie c'est à quelques
centimètres
c'est bouclé est ce qu'on peut
c'est quand même les bacs des géniales
la caméra bien deux parties n'ont visé
des 30 il manquera manger des
bannissements slimani le conducteur le
génie de l'échangé du menu la caméra
étant régine ans et à l'époque puisque
ont été signalés s'il vous plaît est ce
qu'on peut avoir la caméra nautique
slimani si elle ne dort pas merci la
très belle organisation de mille bravos
seller du branché des caméras la syrie
[Rires]
la caméra c'est débranché sans rigoler
ils sont entrain de ces grands lacs
comme des caméras d'habitude les gars
ils ont des caméras sa part tout seul
quand même brushing rade à laissez moi
rigoler au régime bongo à 3 kg tous les
saints pas autant moi beaucoup moins on
est à noter que dire c'est pas la peine
de venir a jusqu'à la fin de la saison
déjà été très bons sur six chiffres
est ce que tu es prêt on va rediffuser
ce qu est ce que tu prête s'il vous
plaît j'aimerais que tout le monde sorte
de l'arrivée qu'on laisse franck seule
sortez tous ces jeunes en peine la régie
merci sortait tout cela je bois de mâcon
et sortez dégager de la régie allez-y
partait partie laissait franck sonne je
me croque soit seul face à cette épreuve
[Rires]
merci merci merci fermé la porte au nez
des galets c'est bon mais n'inquiète pas
des gens tranquilles je vais en diffuser
ce rambo
c'est suite à la diffusion de diageo ce
soir très simplement à la fin de cette
diffusion
je change de numéro prendre avant de te
montrer cette vidéo je vais te dire
franck je t'aime tu es mon président
n'oublie jamais que non n'oublie jamais
que c'est de la parodie est ce que tu
aimes l'humour c'est vrai c'est parti e
on la voit ça sera certainement la
dernière séquence ses marques
ce qui est arrivé est fier d'être moche
mais tu ne dois pas y retomber mais au
midget gens prenaient alors qu'ici je
veux
[Musique]
je veux rambo tout le temps
six à sept avec rambo rang mohammedi
auto rambo sinon je me casse sur ses
stars en acquérir
j'appelle genton
[Musique]
pt 12 heures ensemble on fera des docks
sur les varices de l'ona rambo calme toi
mon bel éphèbe jorion 10 pour rennes
comme des zones dédiées jo ça passe pas
c'est pas moins c'est une tare bats irin
qu'ils décident de tout sur cette chaîne
suite
moi j'ai fais pipi frank s qui décroche
déjà franck moi ça ne me fait pas du
tout rencontre t'aime tu sais mon chéri
[Applaudissements]